これブッダの言葉 まあ釈尊が
人は四つの項目を守るなら大衆に親しまれると説かれたのです
それで私は五つにしたんですけど
お釈迦様は四つにしちゃったんです
これ守ってくださいと
みんなに好かれるぞと教えたんです
この場合は個人がこれ実行しなさいと個人に言ってるんです
この場合は個人で実行できるようにと説かれているのです
1ダン布施 これはギビングコントリビューションということなんですね
これは役に立つという条件の自分の役割です
私はずっと役に立つということについてうるさいほど説明したでしょう
役に立つということは
ブッダの言葉では布施なんですね
布施でも正だけでも施しだけでもいいんですよ
これが役に立つんです
でも これ条件半分しかないんです
自分から役に立つ分 だから自分の役割
役に立つということは
自分の半分は自分が何かしてあげることですね
それやってくださいと
これを仏教用語でダーナというんですね
必要なものを与えたら相互効果になるんですよ
何か与えると言ったっても
役に立たないものを与えるんじゃないんですよ
そうするともう殺されるかもしれません
だからね 大体みんな寄付するそうで言って
もう自分にも他人にも役に立たないものばっかりバンバン出しちゃうでしょうに
あんなのはもう迷惑もいいところで
何の功徳もなりません
ただ自分が見栄張って
私はでは 100 万もあげるぞと
本当は見栄張ってすごく苦労してるんですよ
そんなのはもうものすごい気持ち悪くて
ではなくて 相手に役に立つかと
それだけチェックして役に立つようにしなくちゃいけない
ただ単に人に与えただけでもあるわけじゃないんです
だから人の役に立つことをしているにも関わらず
お布施しているにも関わらず
なんで私は嫌われるでしょうかと悩んでるでしょうに
嫌われてよかったとしか言えないんです
その場合は 寄付をしているんですけどね
なぜならば 役に立たないことばっかりやってるんだからね
だから あの布施の場合は
相手に役に立つということはよく注意しなくては意味がないんです 2
番目はペイエワッジャということなんです
それはまあ 愛語ということで
これは英語の訳ではもっと愛語よりはわかりやすいと思いますけど
この conversationalist ということなんですね
日本語はありません これは行儀作法に入りますが
特に大事な言葉です これでは私が説明した4番目
行儀作法に入るんですよ
私のリストの 4番目 お釈迦様のリストの 2番目
でも その行儀作法の中でも
お釈迦様はさらに切っちゃって言葉だけにしているんです
行儀作法といえば 2つでしょうね
体のマナーと言葉という 2つなんですけど
この場合はそれでマナー
体のマナーは切っちゃって言葉だけしています
だからお釈迦様とお話をする場合は
結構わかりやすくしているんです
やりやすくするんです
だから この人間関係を築きたければ
言葉に気をつける 愛語する
それだけ それが愛語といったっても
ちょこっと頭が悪ければできませんよ
だから英語で言えば conversationalist ということで
まあすごくうまく 何ですかね conversationalist
は まあ日本語はないんだから
その場合はね まあすごく上手に
もういろいろもう対話を保てるとかね
人々とよくしゃべるとかね
かなりの技ですよ  conversationalist といえば
上手に話することはありがたいですが
だからこれがものすごいプロをやってますよ
あのアメリカのテレビなんかでは有名な何人かいるでしょうね
ラリーやられやこれやとかね
結構上手 どんな人ともビシビシと喋られるとかね
日本のマスコミでもあの久米なんとかとか
何でしたっけ？あの人とかね
もうかなりもうすごいしっかりした能力を持ってますよ
こんなのはみんなにできるわけじゃないんですよ
だからここまで我々にはできませんよ
だからできればありがたいんですよ
できないと見る サクションは相手を傷つけ
傷つけないように 相手が楽しくなるようにと心構えれば良いと説かれてます
だから言葉上手とかね
会話上手とか そんなのはどうでもいいんですよ
口下手でもいいんですよ
どもってもいいんですよ
別に でも どもりながらでも
食べる言葉で相手を傷つけてはいけませんよ
それだけ 相手がニコッと楽しくなるんだったら
これで OK なんですよ
だからそんな大胆なことを仏教は期待してないんです
ほんのちょっとのことを気をつけてください
相手がなんか傷つかないようにと言葉に気をつける
それだけ はい 次に行きます
これから早く飛ばします
アッタチャリア これはもう日本訳利己と書きますが
利行です 利己じゃなくて利行と読むでしょうね
まあ英語で言えばアルトリサムなんですね
まあこれ意味はいつでも他人の役に立つように他人に何かしてあげることなんです
仏教では利他利己は別々なものではありません
もう大乗仏教ではね 大乗仏教は利他行であると自慢していますから
かなりガタガタなんですね
だからうまくいかない
だって半分やってないんだから
修行の だからはしごは二本必要でしょ
一本だけだと自慢できないと思いますけどね
だから仏教ではこの利他行も利己行もそんな区別してないんです
別々なものではありません
私の幸福になるものは相手の幸福にもなる
相手の幸福になることは私の幸福にもなる
同じことですよ 例えば嘘をつかないということは
それで私は幸せになるし
嘘を騙されない人々も幸せになるでしょうね
とにかく自分も相手幸福になるものは
というのは誰の幸福になります
人間にとって何が何が幸福を与えるのかと考察して実行することです
ですから このアッタチャリアというのは
人間にとって何が幸福でしょうかと考えて実行してくださいと
これが私が第一条件に説明した役に立つということなんです
4番目にサマーナッタというんですね
これは日本訳は童児と訳していますが
英語で言えばイクアリティなんですね
イコール そちらの名詞イークアリティ
自分も他人も平等だと認めること
実行すること 心に高慢も非難もあってはならない
これは以上説明した人権のことですね
人権を守ろうと 人権を守るということは
生命は平等であるということなんです
だからみんな平等だったら楽でしょうに
付き合う のは皆平等だと理解している人には人に生きることは楽なもんですよ
もし皆様方は大変だ大変と思っているんだったら
人権侵害していますよ
みんな平等だと思っていないんです
偉い人もいるんだと 偉くない人もいるんだと思っているんです
だから大変です 生きることは
生命は平等だとハッキリと理解すると
まあ楽なもんです 生きることは
はい まあそこそこ それで
一応ちょこっと休憩いたします
では始まります これからまあまあ
ただ読むだけではあります
やっとこの今月のテーマに入ります
世間世間知らずとはっていうね
だから読むだけで十分でしょう
人間関係で 人付き合いで会話などをするとき
人生を失敗するとき 使う言葉ですよ
これが世間知らずっていうのは
ただ会話していると あんた世間知らずやと
まあ何のことなく言うことでね
例えば何かやったところで失敗したんだと
世間知らずだからあんた失敗したんだよと軽々くよく使っている言葉なんですよ
それほど深い意味があるわけではありません
まあ講義なんかできるわけないで
世間知らずって ただちょっと三人で喋ってると
何か変なこと言っちゃって
あら お前世間知らずや知らないな
そんなのこと 言うだけのことでしょうに
別にどうったことないです
そんなのは 初めて何か商売に手を出しちゃってうまくいかなかったと
これは経験がないんだからね
俺は世間知らずだからね
そんな風になりますよと
これから という それぐらいのことで
世間知らずと言われても
世間を知り尽くす人間にならなくても結構です
これを覚えてください
世間知らず 世間知らずと我々のことを批判されるかもしれませんよ
だから頑張るかもしれませんだけど
決して世間を知り尽くすということだけはしないでください
これはあまりよくないんですよ
世間のことを知り尽くすということになると
それはあり得ないんです
知り尽くすということは
では 世間を知るためにどうすればいいかと
世間も自分も人間ですからね
人間とは何かと理解すればそうでしょう
世間と言っても人間でしょうし
自分と言っても人間でしょうに
だから人間とは何かと理解する
人間をさておいて 自分を知れば人間を知る
簡単ですよ  世間知るということは
人間を知ることで まあ人間って自分人間だから
人間のことをさておいて
自分を知る 自分を知れば人間を知る
人間を知る人は世間を知る
随分簡単な流れなんです
要するに自己観察することです
だから世間知らず 世間知らずと言われても
百科事典丸暗記するそうとかね
そんな馬鹿なことをやっても
百科事典はもうすぐ新しいもの出ますからね
何年ごとに新しい版が出ますから
暗記したって意味がないんですよ
だから世間知らずと言われたら
世間知る必要じゃなくて
自己観察すれば大丈夫です
知識を得ることではありません
だから世間を知るということは
知識を得ること 知識増えること
勉強することではありません
勉強嫌いな人にもできます
世間知ることは 知識は互い違いでバラバラで結構です
知識っていうのは互い違い
私の知識 皆様の知識 これ違いますからね
それからバラバラでしょ
知識は 同じクラスで同じものを勉強したっても
そのその生徒の生徒の知識はバラバラですよ
それで結構ですよ はい
それから話終わりました
世間知らずはサイド 2つで終わり
それから質問ですけど
で テーマまとめますけど
まあ心理学的にこの世のアプローチで
この内向外向性っていうのはね
良くないと それから中間たる中間性も危険であるということで
どのように人間関係を築いて完璧な人間関係感するのかという
まあ説明してきました
それで皆様に報告されていたのは
世間知らずという言葉で
こんなのは簡単です 世間知らず
世間知る人になるのは簡単です
自己観察すれば それが世間を知ることで
決して知識ではありません
歩いてる 歩いてる百科事典であろうとも
世間知らずは世間知らずです
うん